>> PREVIOUSLY
ON "AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL,"
THE MAKEOVER DRAMA
WAS ONLY THE BEGINNING...
>> YOU HATE YOUR HAIR,
AND--AND YOU'RE ACTUALLY
BEING INSULTING
IN FRONT OF A MASTER.
>> THEN A MAJOR CONFRONTATION
BETWEEN MELROSE AND MONIQUE...
>> NO RESPONSE.
I GOT NOTHING.
>> PUT ALL THE GIRLS ON EDGE.
>> YOU DON'T KNOW WHAT THE HELL
I'M ON THE PHONE
TALKING ABOUT, OKAY?!
I'M NOT HERE TO MAKE FRIENDS
WITH YOU GUYS.
I COULD CARE LESS.
>> THE PHOTO SHOOT WAS ABOUT
SHINING THROUGH
SOME OVER-THE-TOP HAIR.
BUT MEGAN
FADED INTO THE BACKGROUND.
>> THIS IS NOT A GREAT PICTURE.
IN FACT, THIS IS PROBABLY
THE WEAKEST SHOT WE'VE SEEN
OUT OF THE BUNCH.
>> AND SHE WAS SENT HOME.
11 GIRLS REMAIN.
WHO WILL BE ELIMINATED TONIGHT?
♪♪
>> YOU WANNA BE ON TOP?
>> AAH!
>> THIS IS...
THE ULTIMATE
SLIDING CHAMPIONSHIP!
>> WHOO!
>> AAH!
(laughs)
PANEL'S VERY STRESSFUL,
AND SO IT'S FUN
JUST TO JUMP AROUND
AND GET REALLY CRAZY,
'CAUSE ONCE YOU GET TO BE GOOFY,
YOUR NERVOUS ENERGY
KIND OF FADES AWAY.
AAH!
(laughs)
>> I MISS MY OTHER HAIR,
AND NO MATTER HOW MUCH
I WANT IT BACK,
I'M NOT GONNA GET IT BACK
UNTIL IT GROWS OUT.
LAST WEEK,
I WAS IN THE BOTTOM TWO
AND I REALLY FEEL PRESSURED.
>> FEEL LIKE YOU'RE SCARED
OF THAT HAIR.
>> I'M HERE GETTING THIS
BIG OPPORTUNITY, YOU KNOW,
AND I CAN'T SCREW IT OVER
JUST BECAUSE
MY HAIR ISN'T WHAT--
HOW I LIKE IT.
>> I'M SAD THAT MEG'S GONE.
>> BYE, GUYS.
>> I THINK MONIQUE OR EUGENA
SHOULD'VE GONE HOME.
THEY HAD TERRIBLE ATTITUDES.
THEY STILL HAVE
TERRIBLE ATTITUDES.
>> NO, I THINK EVERYONE'S
FEELING THE SAME WAY.
>> (chuckles)
>> HERE'S SOME LOVE FOR YA.
MONIQUE HAS LASHED OUT
ON EVERY PERSON HERE
IN A DIFFERENT WAY.
>> SO YOU GET OUT OF MY FACE
AND GO IN THERE!
>> EVERYONE BUT EUGENA IS LIKE,
"MONIQUE IS REACTING
REALLY INAPPROPRIATELY,
AND SHE DOESN'T KNOW HER LIMIT."
>> TYRA MAIL.
>> "WATCH YOUR STEP BECAUSE
YOUR BUTT IS ON THE LINE."
>> WE'RE GOING BUNGEE JUMPING,
BITCHES.
>> WHAT?
>> WHOO! YES!
>> WHEN WE GET A TYRA MAIL,
I'M JUST THINKING
WHAT IT'S GONNA APPLY TO,
BECAUSE NOTHING THAT
WE'RE DOING HERE IS POINTLESS.
♪♪
>> BUNGEE!
>> OH!
>> WHOO!
>> OH, GOD.
>> MISS J. HAS GOT US DOING...
WHAT?
>> MISS J.
IS TOO FABULOUS.
SHE IS A ROYAL MESS,
AND SHE'S ALWAYS
GOT SOMETHING UP HER SLEEVE
FOR US TO DO.
>> OH, GOODNESS.
>> THERE WAS, LIKE,
A WHOLE CIRCUS THING GOING ON.
THERE WAS A TIGHTROPE.
AND I'M LIKE,
"I'M NOT GETTING UP THERE."
>> WELCOME, LADIES!
SEE THAT, LADIES?
>> OH, MY GOD.
>> POSTURE, BALANCE...
BALANCE, POSTURE.
>> OH, LORD.
CAN I DO THIS?
>> BRAVO.
>> MERCI.
>> YES.
YOU GIRLS WILL BE LEARNING ABOUT
BALANCE AND POSTURE TODAY.
I HAVE HERE
THE MASTERS OF THE WIRE--
RICHIE AND ALEX.
>> WE'RE GONNA TEACH YOU GUYS
TO WALK THIS
HALF-INCH ROPE CABLE.
SO IF YOU CAN WALK THIS,
JUST IMAGINE,
YOU CAN WALK ANYTHING.
>> HEY, Y'ALL WANNA SEE
A BLONDE DO THIS?
I CAN'T EVEN
WALK A STRAIGHT LINE
WHEN I'M DEAD SOBER,
SO HELL IF I'M GONNA
WALK A LITTLE TINY ROPE.
>> SLOW DOWN, SLOW DOWN!
(laughs) THERE YOU GO.
LET GO OF THE ROPE.
KEEP GOING.
(chuckles)
>> BEING IN THIS COMPETITION
IS MORE THAN
WHAT I THOUGHT IT WOULD BE.
I'M JUST TAKING IT
ONE WEEK AT A TIME
AND NOT THINKING ABOUT
BEING AT THE TOP RIGHT NOW.
I'M JUST THINKING,
"MAKE IT TO THE NEXT STAGE."
>> THAT'S IT.
JUST LIKE THAT, OKAY?
GOOD.
YOU GET THROUGH THIS,
THAT CATWALK'S NOTHING.
TRY TO CONCENTRATE
ON THE INSIDE,
BUT SHOW ME SOMETHING
ON THE OUTSIDE, OKAY?
>> LIKE WHAT?
>> LIKE YOU'RE HAVING FUN
WITH IT.
NO WHINING IN MODELING, OKAY?
>> (whines)
>> SMILE.
LET ME SEE YOUR PERSONALITY
COME OUT A LITTLE BIT.
>> LAST WEEK AT ELIMINATIONS,
TYRA TELLS ME
TO SHOW MY EMOTIONS
IF I'M EXCITED ABOUT SOMETHING
AND SHOW THAT I'M EXCITED.
>> YOU'RE PROBABLY WONDERING,
"WHY WAS THAT PICTURE CHOSEN?"
IT WAS THE ONLY PICTURE
THAT YOU GAVE ANYTHING.
IT WAS LIKE YOU WERE ASLEEP
WITH YOUR EYES OPEN
ON THIS SHOOT.
>> SHE'S NOT SMILING, IS SHE?
>> BOTH ME AND MY SISTER,
WE'VE ALWAYS HAD PROBLEMS
WITH OUR FEET.
MY SISTER'S FEET
ARE REALLY FLAT-FEETED.
>> YOU'RE PIGEON-TOED HERE.
>> CAN I HAVE
A 1-WAY TICKET, PLEASE?
I DON'T LIKE THIS.
>> NO, IT'S A ROUND-TRIP TICKET.
THERE YOU GO. GOOD.
NO, THE OTHER WAY.
>> AAH!
>> THAT'S IT.
NICE AND STRAIGHT.
>> UH-OH.
>> FIND THAT BALANCE.
I SEE YOU'RE STARTING
TO FEEL REALLY COMFORTABLE
UP THERE, HUH?
>> LET'S JUST HOPE I DON'T FALL
AND SCREW IT ALL UP.
>> GOOD.
LOOK, SHE'S WALKING LIKE
SHE HAS THE HEELS ON.
PERFECT.
>> MELROSE--SHE JUST ACTS LIKE
SHE'S JUST SO PERFECT,
AND SHE'S NOT.
>> LET GO OF THE ROPES.
GO, GO, GO, GO, GO, GO, GO, GO,
GO, GO, GO!
THERE YOU GO!
>> WHOO! YEAH!
>> AWESOME.
PUT YOUR ARMS OUT,
AND THEN I WANNA
SEE YOU SELL IT.
>> HEY!
>> PERFECT, PERFECT.
>> I'M JUST TRYING
TO AVOID MONIQUE.
YOU KNOW,
I WISH SHE WASN'T HERE,
BUT BECAUSE SHE IS,
THAT'S JUST WHAT IT IS.
>> FIND YOUR BALANCE.
>> HOLD ON.
MELROSE--SHE JUST HAS TO BE
THE BETTER PERSON ALL THE TIME.
BUT RIGHT NOW,
I JUST NEED TO FOCUS
ON GETTING BETTER
AND SHOWING THAT
I AM TOP MODEL MATERIAL.
AAH!
>> (laughing)
♪♪
>> TYRA MAIL!
"WE'D LOVE TO BE
IN AN EXPENSIVE DESIGNER FROCK,
BUT TOMORROW,
YOU'LL ROCK YOUR OWN LINE.
LOVE, TYRA."
>> OOH!
>> WHOA!
>> (laughs)
(telephone rings)
>> Hello?
>> HI, MAMA.
>> Hey, how's it going?
>> IT'S LIKE...
(makes whooshing sound)
THE DOOR COMES FLYING OPEN.
MONIQUE'S LIKE,
"I WAS, LIKE, DA DA DA!"
>> I SPECIFICALLY CALLED FIRST
FOR THE PHONE.
>> I'LL BE DONE IN, LIKE,
20 MINUTES, MONIQUE.
>> IF A PERSON CALLS FOR IT,
THEN I SHOULDN'T HAVE TO WAIT.
>> THIS IS THE GIRL
I'M TALKING ABOUT.
I JUST WANTED HER
TO LEAVE MY SPACE.
YOU KNOW, LET ME HAVE MY SPACE.
>> THIS IS WHAT
I'M TALKING ABOUT.
>> Ignore her for the moment.
>> ANIMALS, BE CALM.
>> IT'S LIKE DEALING
WITH CHILDREN.
CAN YOU MOVE, PLEASE?
>> SHE JUST...
(door closes)
>> OH, GUYS,
PLEASE DON'T START ANYTHING.
I DON'T KNOW HOW YOU CAN
BE FIGHTING ALL THE TIME.
THE DRAMA IS SOMETIMES
A LITTLE BIT OVERWHELMING.
>> (chuckles)
(telephone rings)
>> Hello?
>> MOM, I'M ABOUT
TO... A GIRL UP.
EXCUSE MY FRENCH.
I'M ABOUT TO--
I'M ABOUT TO REALLY HURT HER.
I HAVE NEVER, EVER
DESPISED ANYBODY SO MUCH BEFORE
IN MY LIFE LIKE I DO MELROSE.
AND SHE WENT, BAM!
AND JUST WENT LIKE THAT,
AND I WAS LIKE...
(choked voice)
"ALL RIGHT. OKAY."
>> MONIQUE--
SHE'S VERY STRESSED OUT.
SHE CAN'T CONTROL HER EMOTIONS.
THIS MIGHT BE TOO MUCH FOR HER.
>> ALL THESE GIRLS IN HERE
ARE BITCHES AND HOS!
THAT'S ALL I GOTTA SAY.
HOES.
I'M HAVING THE MUSTY ARMS
RIGHT NOW,
AND I JUST WONDERING--
SINCE MELROSE THINKS
I'M THIS BIG MONSTER--
IF I WAS JUST TO GO LIKE THIS
OVER HER BED,
WHAT WOULD SHE DO?
YOU DARE ME TO DO IT?
>> (laughing)
>> (laughs)
>> SHE JUST WIPED SOMETHING
ON MY BED.
>> (whispers) THAT'S SO ICKY!
>> I RUBBED IT
ALL OVER HER SHEETS.
(laughing)
>> THAT'S SO GROSS!
THAT'S SO GROSS!
SHE'S CRAZY.
LIKE, WE'RE AFRAID
THAT MAYBE SHE'LL, LIKE,
CHOP UP ALL OF OUR CLOTHES.
>> SHE'S CAPABLE OF ANYTHING,
AND THAT'S--I HATE THAT.
I HATE THAT SHE'S IN THIS HOUSE.
>> OH, MY GOD, I'M FREAKING OUT.
SHE'S GONNA COME IN
IN THE MIDDLE OF THE NIGHT
AND THROW, LIKE, LEMONADE ON ME.
>> YES, YES, YES.
WHAT ELSE CAN I DO?
♪♪
>> THAT'S THE THING.
IT'S JUST LIKE, "WHAT?"
(laughs)
>> YOU HAVE TO ADMIT
THAT YOU DID TOUCH THE BED.
>> YEAH.
>> MONIQUE AND MELROSE
JUST KEEP GOING AT EACH OTHER.
SHE DOES ONE THING,
THEN MONIQUE
HAS TO GET HER BACK.
IT'S REALLY IMMATURE,
BOTH OF THEM.
>> SHE LEAVE ME ALONE,
SHE AIN'T GOTTA WORRY
ABOUT ME BOTHERING HER.
BUT IF SHE KEEPS BOTHERING ME,
THEN YES,
THERE'S GONNA BE PROBLEMS.
>> UGH, EVERYTHING'S A BIG DEAL.
WHEN YOU'RE APPROACHED
BY SOMEONE
WHO HAS NO RESPECT
OR COMPASSION FOR OTHER PEOPLE--
LIKE MONIQUE--
IT'S HARD TO BE ABLE
TO DEAL WITH SOMEONE LIKE THAT.
I KNOW HOW TO DEFEND MYSELF.
HONESTLY,
I'VE HAD GIRLS ATTACK ME
MANY TIMES IN MY LIFE.
MONIQUE HAS NOTHING.
>> THE ONLY THING--
>> THE ONLY REASON
MONIQUE IS DOING THIS
IS BECAUSE SHE CAN'T
GET ATTENTION OTHERWISE.
SHE HAS NO PERSONALITY.
I'M NOT GONNA
TRY AND MAKE UP WITH HER,
'CAUSE HER NOT
GETTING ALONG WITH ME
IS MAKING HER COMPETE WORSE,
AND I AM HERE TO WIN.
>> I'M INTERESTED TO SEE
WHAT OUR TYRA MAIL MEANT
FROM LAST NIGHT.
I THINK WE'RE GONNA
BE DESIGNING OUR OWN DRESSES
AND MAYBE WALKING IN THEM.
>> HI!
>> (cheering)
>> HEY!
>> OH, MY!
>> MISS J.!
>> (cheering)
>> EVERY TIME WE SEE J.,
HE'S IN SOMETHING MORE RADICAL
AND MORE EXTREME,
HILARIOUS.
>> YESTERDAY,
YOU LEARNED ALL ABOUT...
BALANCE,
AND TODAY, YOU'RE GONNA
BE PUT TO THE TEST.
I HAVE TO BRING OUT
ONE OF THE MODELS
FROM THE PAST SEASON
WHO WAS
ONE OF THE BEST WALKERS YET.
MISS BRE,
COME ON OUT, GIRL.
>> (cheering)
>> WHEN I'M ON A RUNWAY,
IT'S MY SPOTLIGHT
AND IT'S MY TIME,
AND IT IS ALL ABOUT MISS BRE.
>> THE FOCUS OF THIS CHALLENGE
IS FOR YOU TO LEARN
HOW TO WALK A STRAIGHT LINE
ON BROKEN SLABS OF CONCRETE
WITH HIGH HEELS AND ALSO
TO BE POISED AND BALANCED.
WHAT I HAVE
FOR YOU GIRLS BACKSTAGE
IS A FEW EVENING GOWNS,
HEELS AND...
>> MASKS.
>> LADIES, YOU HAVE FIVE MINUTES
TO GET READY.
>> WHOO!
>> I HATE POINTY-TOED SHOES.
>> OH, MY GOD!
THE MASKS--WE FIND OUT--
YOU COULD BARELY
SEE ANYTHING OUT OF,
SO WE'RE BASICALLY
WALKING BLIND ON COBBLESTONES.
>> ALL RIGHT, TIME'S UP, LADIES.
LET'S GO.
>> BAM, BAM!
OOH, IT'LL BE JUST LIKE
THE TIGHTROPE.
>> THIS SHOULD BE GOOD.
ROCK THE ROCKS
THAT YOU'RE WALKING ON, BABY.
SEXY, FASTER
OH!
SEXY, FASTER.
COME ON, GIRL.
>> VERY SEXY.
>> OH!
YES, 'CAUSE SHE'S HAD
ONE DRINK TOO MANY.
LET'S GO.
PUT THE MUSIC IN YOUR HEAD.
>> STAY FOCUSED.
>> BRING ME SEXY.
MICHELLE NEEDS TO WALK
LIKE A GIRL, BUT A SEXY GIRL.
KEEP IT MOVING, KEEP IT MOVING.
RIGHT ON THE LINE.
STRAIGHT ON THE LINE.
>> I FIND THAT
I ACTUALLY NATURALLY
WALK IN A STRAIGHT LINE.
LIKE, MY FEET JUST GO
ONE IN FRONT OF THE OTHER.
>> SOME OF YOU GIRLS
LEARNED SOMETHING YESTERDAY
ON THAT LINE.
GREAT.
JAEDA, I NEED IT FASTER.
BALANCE, POSTURE, BALANCE.
>> VERY SEXY WALK.
>> HARD, STRONG, SEXY,
NASTY, ATTITUDE.
>> I DON'T THINK--
I'M JUST GONNA ACT LIKE
I'M OKAY.
I KNOW THAT I NEED
TO STEP UP, YOU KNOW,
A LITTLE BIT MORE.
>> BRE LOVES YOUR ENERGY.
WHAT WE DON'T LIKE
IS THE BIG STEPS.
>> OH!
>> THAT'S ALL RIGHT. RECOVER.
>> OH, YOU LOST
YOUR CONFIDENCE, BABY.
MELROSE STUMBLED
MANY, MANY TIMES.
SHE DIDN'T RECOVER
LIKE A MODEL SHOULD HAVE.
>> MELROSE--
SHE ALWAYS OVERREACTS...
(imitates Melrose) "AAH!
OH, MY GOD,
I'M GOING TO DIE!"
>> WALK LIKE
YOU'RE WALKING THROUGH HELL
IN GASOLINE-SOAKED PAJAMAS.
EUGENA--I THOUGHT SHE HAD
ONE OF THE SAFEST WALKS.
SHE HASN'T STEPPED UP
TO THE PLATE YET.
WIND IN THE HAIR,
WIND IN THE HAIR.
FASHION MODEL.
>> PRESERVE YOUR SEXY, HONEY.
PRESERVE YOUR SEXY.
>> NEXT GIRL, LET'S GO!
>> KEEP YOUR BALANCE.
JUST TRY A LITTLE QUICKER.
DON'T LOSE YOUR CONSISTENCY.
>> COME ON BACK HERE, GIRL.
WALK A LITTLE SEXY,
A LITTLE HOTTER,
A LITTLE FASTER.
YOU ARE THE SEX KITTEN
IN THE HOUSE.
OOH, YES!
>> I GOT ONE.
>> AN EXTRA TURN, YES!
WHEE!
THE GIRL WHO WINS
THIS CHALLENGE
WILL GET TO FLY AWAY TOMORROW
AND MODEL IN
THE DENNIS QUAID
CHARITY WEEKEND FASHION SHOW,
WHICH RAISES MONEY
FOR CHILDREN'S CHARITIES
IN AUSTIN, TEXAS.
>> OH!
>> THAT'S MY HOME TOWN!
>> SO THE WINNER
OF THIS CHALLENGE
IS A.J.
>> (cheering)
>> ALL RIGHT, A.J.!
>> NOW, A.J...
>> YES?
>> GETS TO CHOOSE TWO GIRLS
WHO WILL ALSO MODEL WITH HER
IN THE FASHION SHOW AS WELL.
>> ALL RIGHT, CHOOSE WISELY.
>> I WANNA GO HOME.
>> I WANT MEGG.
>> (cheering)
I WAS LIKE,
"YEAH! ROCK AND ROLL!
THIS IS SO RAD! LET'S GO!"
>> I WANNA GO HOME.
>> BROOKE'S HOMETOWN IS AUSTIN,
AND SHE'S LIKE,
"I WANNA GO HOME!"
>> THAT'S MY HOMETOWN!
>> "A.J., PICK ME!"
AND I WAS JUST LIKE,
"OH, BROOKE, HONEY, LIKE,
I WOULD TOTALLY LOVE
TO TAKE YOUR HOME, BUT..."
ALL RIGHT, CARIDEE.
>> (cheering)
(laughing)
>> THAT SUCKS.
JUST TO GO HOME
FOR A LITTLE BIT,
IT WOULD'VE BEEN NICE,
AND I'M--I DON'T WANNA
GET ALL TEARY ABOUT IT,
BUT I LOVE TEXAS.
THAT'S MY HOME STATE.
♪♪
>> AFTER IT WAS OVER,
I WAS REALLY
STARTING TO GET SICK.
MY HEAD WAS, LIKE, HURTING,
LIKE, REALLY, REALLY BAD.
ONE MINUTE,
I'LL BE REALLY, REALLY HOT.
THE NEXT MINUTE,
I'D BE REALLY, REALLY COLD.
>> I JUST THINK
ALL THAT NEGATIVE ENERGY
SHE PUT OUT THERE
THOSE FIRST TWO WEEKS
IS BREEDING ON ITSELF.
MAYBE SHE REALLY
MADE HERSELF SICK.
♪♪
>> MORNING.
YOU HAVE A VERY PLEASANT TRIP.
WELCOME ON AMERICAN.
>> YAY!
♪♪
>> HI.
>> WE'RE AT THE DENNIS QUAID
CELEBRITY FASHION WEEKEND.
>> I WANTED TO INTRODUCE
YOU GUYS TO SOME MODELS
YOU MIGHT KNOW--
>> HI, GUYS!
>> HI!
>> WHAT'S UP?
>> IT WAS COOL TO SEE
ALL THE OTHER MODELS
FROM PREVIOUS CYCLES,
AND I WISH I COULD'VE
GOT A LITTLE ADVICE FROM THEM.
>> YOU GUYS EXCITED?
>> WELL, YEAH.
>> OH, YEAH, WE'RE EXCITED.
>> IT WAS GOOD TO MEET THEM,
'CAUSE THEY USED TO BE
IN MY SHOES.
>> EVERY MONTH,
I'M IN A DIFFERENT COUNTRY,
TRAVELING THE WORLD.
>> WOW.
>> REALLY?
>> IT'S AN AMAZING EXPERIENCE.
>> GREAT.
>> I'M GLAD THEY'RE HERE.
IT'S A LITTLE MORE CALMING.
NOT SO INTIMIDATING.
>> SEE YOU ON THE RUNWAY?
>> OKAY.
>> ALL RIGHT.
>> HEY, CAN YOU STOP PRACTICING
FOR A MINUTE?
>> YEAH!
IT'S MY FIRST TIME
REALLY MEETING
STARS AND FAMOUS PEOPLE,
BEING FROM A SMALL TOWN.
THANKS!
>> THANKS FOR HELPING US OUT.
THIS IS GREAT.
>> THANKS FOR HAVING US MODEL.
>> PUMPING UP THE VIBE IN HERE.
IT'S ALL GOOD.
>> I WAS SO GRATEFUL
THAT A.J. PICKED ME.
I KNEW I WAS GONNA BE
IN MY FIRST FASHION RUNWAY SHOW
WITH DESIGNER OUTFITS
AND DENNIS QUAID.
I WAS REALLY, REALLY,
REALLY EXCITED.
>> THAT WAS AWESOME, DUDE.
>> WE WANNA WELCOME YOU ALL
TO "LIGHTS, CAMERA, FASHION."
>> (cheering)
♪♪
>> IT WAS QUITE
AN ADRENALINE RUSH, ACTUALLY,
'CAUSE YOU'VE GOT
THE BOOMING MUSIC,
AND YOU'RE JUST KIND OF LIKE,
"YEAH, I'M BADASS."
>> AND I WAS FEEDING OFF
THE WHOLE CROWD'S ENERGY,
AND WHEN I WENT OUT THERE,
I'M JUST LIKE, "LET'S DO IT.
LET'S JUST ROCK AND ROLL."
>> (cheering)
>> ONCE I HIT THE LIGHT,
I'VE NEVER HAD SUCH A, LIKE,
CLEAR MOMENT.
I JUST WANNA SAVOR IT,
'CAUSE YOU NEVER KNOW
WHAT COULD HAPPEN TOMORROW,
BUT TONIGHT I FULFILLED
A PART OF MY DREAM.
(cheering)
>> GUYS, TYRA MAIL!
"IT'S TIME TO WALK THE PLANK.
LOVE, TYRA."
>> WHOO!
>> WE'RE GONNA
DRESS UP AS PIRATES!
I LOVE PIRATES!
>> DO YOU NEED WATER?
>> NO, I COULD NOT DRINK IT.
I'M AFRAID
I'M GONNA THROW IT UP.
>> I'LL SEND MY PRAYERS
FOR YOU TO FEEL BETTER, OKAY?
>> MM-HMM.
MONIQUE IS REALLY SICK.
SHE LOOKS LIKE DEATH.
>> MONIQUE IS GETTING
SICKER AND SICKER
BY THE HOUR.
>> I CAN'T KEEP NOTHING DOWN.
>> I'M KIND OF SCARED FOR HER,
AND I THINK SHE NEEDS
TO GO TO THE HOSPITAL.
WELL, HOPEFULLY,
THEY'LL FIND OUT
WHAT'S WRONG WITH HER,
SO SHE'LL BE ABLE
TO PERFORM TOMORROW.
>> THE EXPERIENCE
AT THE HOSPITAL WAS JUST--
IT WAS SO MISERABLE.
THE DOCTOR COMES AND SEES ME,
AND HE'S LIKE,
"WELL, YOU'RE DEHYDRATED,"
LIKE, "YOU NEED, LIKE,
FLUIDS FAST."
THERE'S JUST SO MUCH
GOING ON IN MY HEAD,
YOU KNOW?
SCARY.
♪♪
>> WHOO!
>> THIS MORNING,
WE ALL ASKED MONIQUE
IF SHE WAS GONNA GET OUT OF BED.
SHE SAID SHE'S GONNA
TOUGH IT OUT BECAUSE
SHE HAS TO HAVE A PHOTO SHOOT.
>> TAKE LOTS AND LOTS
OF VITAMINS.
I DON'T CARE IF SHE'S THERE.
THIS IS A COMPETITION.
I'M HERE TO DO MY JOB.
>> I'M-A JUST SUCK IT UP
AND TRY TO GRAB SOME STRENGTH
FROM SOMEWHERE
AND TRY TO GET THERE.
♪♪
>> WE WENT STRAIGHT OFF
THE AIRPLANE AFTER, LIKE,
THREE HOURS OF SLEEP
AND NOT EVEN 24 HOURS IN TEXAS,
AND WENT STRAIGHT
TO THE NEXT PHOTO SHOOT.
♪♪
>> HEY!
>> HEY, LOOK WHO IT IS--
THE JET-SET GIRLS!
>> HI!
>> WELL, Y'ALL LOOK
KIND OF TIRED,
DRAGGING YOURSELVES
OUT OF THAT CAR THIS MORNING.
YOU GIRLS ARE GOING TO BE
IN A RUNWAY SHOW,
AND YOUR PHOTO SHOOT
IS ACTUALLY GONNA BE
A PHOTOGRAPHER
THAT'S IN THE PHOTO PEN
AT THE END OF THE RUNWAY.
CHARLIE, WHO IS YOUR STYLIST,
IS A VERY ACCOMPLISHED
DESIGNER HIMSELF,
ALONG WITH HIS PARTNER EMILIANO.
AND TODAY, YOU'LL ACTUALLY
BE WEARING THEIR DRESSES
ON THE RUNWAY.
>> YOU HAVE TO BE SUPER CAREFUL,
BECAUSE THERE'S
A LOT OF PIECES THAT
ARE SUPER-DELICATE ORGANZAS,
THAT ANY LITTLE MOVE YOU MAKE
COULD RIP.
>> RIGHT NOW,
I'M FEELING REALLY PUMPED UP
BECAUSE I FEEL LIKE
I OWN THE RUNWAY.
♪♪
>> I WAS GONNA STAY HOME,
BUT I WAS LIKE, "NO, LET ME GO."
>> MMM.
>> AND I WOULD'VE BEEN PISSED
IF I DIDN'T GO AND...
>> SEE IF YOU CAN SIT DOWN.
LIKE, LAY DOWN IN THE BED
OR SOMETHING LIKE THAT.
SHE WAS IN BED ALL DAY
THE NIGHT BEFORE,
AND I'M REALLY PROUD OF HER
FOR COMING OUT.
>> HOW ARE YOU?
>> NOT SO GOOD.
>> WHY? WHAT'S WRONG?
>> I'M SICK.
I JUST--I WANTED
TO JUST LAY DOWN SOMEWHERE.
I WAS JUST SO WEAK.
>> IF YOU WANT TO GO BACK
TO THE HOUSE,
I WILL HAVE THE DRIVER
COME AND PICK YOU UP
SO YOU CAN GO BACK TO SLEEP.
HEY, I WANT YOU TO MAKE
THE RIGHT DECISION,
BUT YOU HAVE TO MAKE THAT
FOR YOURSELF.
>> I'LL JUST
TAKE THE THING HOME THEN.
>> YOU WANNA TAKE THE RIDE HOME?
OKAY.
>> LIKE, MY HEART AND MY MIND--
IT'S LIKE, "BE HERE
AND STAY AND DO THIS."
BUT MY BODY IS LIKE,
"YOU CAN'T,"
AND IT SUCKS SO BAD.
>> DANIELLE ON SEASON SIX--
SHE WAS REALLY, REALLY SICK,
HAD I.V.s IN HER ARM--
AND INSTEAD OF, YOU KNOW,
SAYING, "OH, OKAY, I WON'T GO,"
SHE, LIKE, WENT TO THE SHOOT,
AND, LIKE, ROCKED IT.
>> SO YOU GUYS ARE STARTING
TO LOOK LIKE MODELS.
>> YEAH!
>> YOU'RE AMPED?
OKAY, LET'S GO
AND TAKE A LOOK AT THE RUNWAY.
>> LET'S DO IT!
>> WHOO!
WHOO!
>> OH!
>> WE LOOK,
AND THERE'S THIS RUNWAY
RIGHT IN THE MIDDLE OF A POOL.
WE'RE LIKE, "OH, MY GOD."
>> SO IT'S--IT'S, AGAIN,
TO ENTICE THE AUDIENCE,
TO MAKE IT SOMETHING NEW,
SOMETHING SPECIAL.
>> AND WE'RE LIKE...
"IN THE POOL?
ARE YOU KIDDING ME?!"
>> I'VE WALKED IT ALL AFTERNOON,
AND CLEARLY, I'M FINE.
SO WE READY TO FIT OUR CLOTHES?
>> YEAH!
>> OKAY, LET'S GO.
THIS IS NOT UNREALISTIC.
THESE GIRLS HAVE TO BE PREPARED
TO DO ALMOST ANYTHING
TO SELL A GARMENT.
>> I'M GONNA ROCK IT TODAY
ON THE RUNWAY.
I'M GONNA KEEP THAT ADRENALINE
THAT I HAD YESTERDAY AND USE IT.
>> ALL RIGHT, WE READY?
THIS IS FIERCE?
I'M WAITING FOR FIERCE.
BROOKE WAS ACTUALLY
PRETTY COMPOSED.
IT WAS REALLY DIFFICULT
BEING FIRST UP.
>> I START WALKING, AND, LIKE,
WHAT THE HELL?
IT, LIKE, STARTS TIPPING,
AND, LIKE, I ALMOST FALL IN.
>> ALL RIGHT, SHE NAILED IT!
HER FOOTWORK WAS A LITTLE OFF,
BUT OVERALL,
JAEDA HELD HER COMPOSURE,
AND I WAS REALLY IMPRESSED
BY THAT.
DON'T SLOW IT DOWN!
DON'T SLOW IT DOWN.
YOU GOTTA KEEP IT UP.
HER WHOLE BOOB IS OUT!
>> WHOO!
>> HEY, IT'S FASHION, HONEY.
BOOBS DO PEEKABOO
IN FASHION SHOWS.
>> I LOVED
WHEN CARIDEE'S TOP
EXPOSED HER BREAST.
I THINK IT WAS AWESOME.
IT WAS SO PARIS.
>> I KNOW MISS J.
WOULD DIE IN HORROR
LOOKING AT WHAT CARIDEE DID.
I MEAN, WHERE WAS THE MODEL?
>> WHAT I WAS
REALLY THINKING WAS,
"GET BACK DRY, GET BACK DRY,
GET BACK DRY."
>> ENERGY, MEGG! ENERGY!
LIKE, SERIOUSLY, IS SHE ASLEEP?
SHE'S LIKE...
A.J., GIVE ME SOME ENERGY,
PLEASE, GIRL.
THERE YOU GO, DAMN IT.
WORK IT.
A.J.--WHEN SHE STEPPED OUT
INTO THE SPOTLIGHT
AND POSED IN FRONT OF RUNWAY--
LOOKED ABSOLUTELY BREATHTAKING.
DON'T SLOW IT DOWN.
MICHELLE OWNED
THE END OF THE RUNWAY.
AMANDA WAS ONE OF THE GIRLS
WHO WAS THE BEST
AT KEEPING UP HER PACE
IN THIS RUNWAY SHOW.
WORK IT, EUGENA.
>> I JUST HAVE TO MAKE SURE
THAT IN EACH SHOT
I'M GIVING
SOME SORT OF EMOTION,
SO HOPEFULLY IT COMES OUT WELL.
>> POSE, POSE.
WITH EUGENA, I WAS REALLY HOPING
TO SEE MORE LIFE,
BUT I DIDN'T.
SHE WAS TOTALLY FLAT.
>> (murmuring)
>> AS SOON AS I STEPPED ON IT
WITH ONE FOOT,
I, LIKE, SLID.
I KEPT GOING AFTER I FELL OFF.
I JUST KEPT GOING.
I'M FRICKIN' BLEEDING!
>> OKAY, MELROSE, COME ON.
PICK UP THAT SPEED!
OH, OH, MY GOSH,
SHE LOOKS GREAT.
MELROSE WORKED IT,
AND SHE LOOKED CONFIDENT
EVEN WHILE WOBBLING.
ALL RIGHT, GIRLS,
I WANT YOU TO LINE UP
FOR YOUR FINALE WALK.
GO, ANCHAL!
IF ANYONE WAS SMART,
THEY'D JUST PUSH THE OTHER GIRL
IN THE POOL.
>> I TRIED AS MUCH
TO KEEP MY MODEL POSTURE
IN MY COUTURE DRESS,
LOOKING GOOD,
BUT IT WAS VERY CRAZY.
>> GO, AMANDA!
GO, AMANDA!
(laughs)
>> JAY!
>> JAY, JAY, JAY!
>> HONESTLY,
IN MONIQUE'S CONDITION,
SHE WOULDN'T HAVE
BEEN ABLE TO DO IT.
WE WERE ALL WELL,
AND WE REALLY SUCKED.
THAT WAS, LIKE,
ONE OF THE HARDEST THINGS
I'VE EVER DONE.
IT WAS SO SCARY.
>> THEN I PROBABLY
WOULD'VE FAILED
BECAUSE I'M SO WEAK.
>> TYRA MAIL, LADIES!
"TOMORROW, YOU WILL MEET
WITH THE JUDGES.
ONLY TEN WILL CONTINUE ON
IN HOPES OF BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL..."
>> I AM SO NERVOUS.
>> "LOVE, TYRA."
>> (cheering)
>> AY, YI, YI!
>> SOMEBODY'S GOING HOME.
>> I'M SO GLAD ALL OF YOU
CAME INTO MY LIFE.
IT'S JUST COOL TO MEET GIRLS
THAT ARE, LIKE, REAL.
PANEL IS ALWAYS
A NERVE-RACKING TIME.
MY DREAMS ARE
IN SOMEBODY ELSE'S HANDS.
>> I, HONESTLY, HAVE NOT A CLUE
WHO'S GOING HOME.
IF IT WAS JUST BASED
ON THE RUNWAY LAST NIGHT,
I WOULD SAY...
EUGENA.
>> HONESTLY, I DON'T KNOW.
I-I WOULD'VE STAYED, I THINK.
I WOULD'VE, LIKE,
LAID DOWN ALL DAY,
GOT MY MAKEUP DONE--
>> I'D BE, LIKE,
PUKING IN A BUCKET BACKSTAGE,
AND THEN WALKING AND TRYING
NOT TO PUKE ON THE STAGE.
I DON'T KNOW IF--
BECAUSE THE DOCTOR SAYS
NOT TO WORK--
THAT THAT MEANS
THAT YOU CAN'T WORK.
I MEAN,
MAYBE GOD'S PLACE FOR MONIQUE
JUST ISN'T HERE.
>> I'VE NEVER BEEN SICK
LIKE THIS BEFORE...
EVER.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT
I'M GONNA TELL THE JUDGES.
♪♪
>> HELLO, LADIES.
>> HI, TYRA!
>> SO HOW MANY OF YOU GIRLS
STAND BEFORE ME?
WHAT IS THAT--11 OF YOU?
BUT UNFORTUNATELY,
SOMEBODY HAS TO GO HOME TODAY.
BUT FIRST, LET'S TALK ABOUT
THESE AMAZING PRIZES
THAT THE WINNER
OF "AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL"
WILL RECEIVE.
THE FIRST IS A CONTRACT
WITH ELITE MODEL MANAGEMENT,
WHICH IS ONE OF THE WORLD'S
TOP MODEL AGENCIES...
A COVER OF "SEVENTEEN" MAGAZINE,
AND NOT ONLY IS IT A COVER,
IT'S A 6-PAGE SPREAD...
AND A $100,000 CONTRACT
WITH COVERGIRL COSMETICS.
ALL RIGHT, SO LET'S START WITH
THESE JUDGES.
WE ALL KNOW
THE LOVELY, SEXY NIGEL BARKER,
NOTED FASHION PHOTOGRAPHER...
AND LEGENDARY RUNWAY COACH
MISS J. ALEXANDER....
FASHION ICON
AND LIVING LEGEND TWIGGY...
>> AW, THANK YOU, TYRA.
>> AND MR. CHARLIE ALTUNA,
WHO IS HALF OF THE DESIGN TEAM
OF ALTUNA MORENO,
AND HE DESIGNED THE CLOTHES
FOR THAT VERY WOBBLY
FASHION SHOW PHOTO SHOOT
THAT YOU ALL HAD.
THIS WEEK, YOU LEARNED
ALL ABOUT RUNWAY WALKING
AND HOW BALANCE IS SO IMPORTANT.
SO THAT'S WHAT YOUR JUDGING TEST
IS ABOUT TODAY--
SHOWING YOUR SIGNATURE WALK
BUT ALSO INCORPORATING BALANCE,
AND YOU'RE GONNA HAVE TO BALANCE
THESE ITEMS...
ON TOP OF YOUR HEAD.
>> (laughs)
>> OH, MY.
>> BUT WE'RE GONNA
GIVE YOU A LITTLE HELP--
YOU'RE GONNA BALANCE THESE ITEMS
INSIDE OF THIS...
NNENNA FROM "TOP MODEL" SEASON 6
CAN DO IT,
SO CAN YOU.
SO COME GET YOUR PROP.
TAKE YOUR TIME.
GET IT RIGHT.
(laughs)
>> (laughs)
♪♪
>> DO YOU HAVE A CONE UP THERE?
>> (scoffs)
>> SOME HAIRSPRAY
WOULD HAVE HELPED.
>> (laughs)
>> (laughing)
>> GET A FIERCE FACE.
WORK IT OUT.
(whispers) YES.
>> (mouths words)
>> (laughs)
>> OKAY.
>> (laughter)
>> HEY, WHERE'S THE FRUIT?
>> ♪ WAH-WAH ♪
>> AH!
(grunts) YES!
>> WHOO!
>> (laughter)
>> (scoffs)
>> YOU MAKE IT WORK.
>> (laughter)
>> ALL RIGHT,
SO NOW IT'S TIME
FOR YOUR INDIVIDUAL EVALUATIONS.
AND AFTER THAT,
THE JUDGES WILL DELIBERATE,
AND WE WILL DETERMINE
WHICH ONE OF YOU
WILL BE ELIMINATED.
SO THE FIRST IS JAEDA.
SO, JAEDA,
YOU'RE ONE OF THE GIRLS
THAT WASN'T MISS DROPPY-DROPPY.
YOU ARE THE GIRL THAT PROVES
THAT IT CAN BE DONE.
YOU HAD A PHOTO SHOOT.
YOU HAD TO WALK
ON A VERY UNSTABLE RUNWAY.
SO WE WERE TESTING
HOW WELL YOU CAN
KEEP YOUR FACE CONTROLLED,
AND IF YOU CAN
CAPTURE THAT ON A PHOTO.
THIS BODY POSE IS MEH.
IT'S ABOUT SELLING AN OUTFIT.
SO I SEE CHARLIE'S
GORGEOUS CREATION,
BUT I DON'T FEEL LIKE
YOU'RE SELLING IT.
>> I ACTUALLY THINK
IT'S REALLY STRONG,
AND I ACTUALLY SAID
I WANT THE OUTFIT,
SO YOU'VE SOLD IT TO ME.
>> THAT'S GOOD.
>> AMANDA.
>> I DON'T THINK
THE BOWL STAYED ON YOUR HEAD
FOR, LIKE, ONE SECOND.
IT WAS SO MESSY.
>> SO LET'S SEE
IF YOU WERE A MESS
AT YOUR FASHION SHOW.
>> THIS IS A GOOD SHOT.
YOU'VE GOT BALANCE.
YOU HAVE DETERMINATION
IN YOUR EYES.
I BELIEVE IT.
>> I WENT THROUGH YOUR FILM
AND I SAW THIS SHOT,
AND I WAS LIKE,
"I WOULD BUY THAT DRESS."
I LIKE IT.
UP NEXT IS MICHELLE.
I FELT LIKE YOU DIDN'T CARE.
WHEN YOU WERE DOING THE WALK,
IT FELT LIKE
YOU JUST THREW IT AWAY
AND YOU DIDN'T CARE
AND IT WASN'T IMPORTANT TO YOU.
>> IT WAS A WEIRD WALK...
>> CHARLIE, THE BOWL...
>> AND IT WAS CHOPPY AND SLOPPY.
CHOPPY, SLOPPY.
>> CHOPPY, SLOPPY
MAKES A GREAT FRUIT SALAD.
>> SEEING YOUR PHOTOGRAPH,
YOU PHOTOGRAPH VERY WELL.
BUT WHEN YOU GO INTO A ROOM,
IT'S SLIGHTLY UNGAINLY
AND MAKES ME FEEL
SLIGHTLY UNCOMFORTABLE.
>> THIS OUTFIT--I WANT IT
TO BE COLD IN CALIFORNIA
SO I CAN WEAR THAT FAKE FUR
THAT YOU ARE ROCKING.
NEXT IS MEGG.
>> I LOVE YOUR PERSONALITY,
AND I-I WARM TOWARDS THAT.
>> (imitates Megg)
"ROCK AND ROLL!"
>> (laughter)
>> SOMETHING REALLY WEIRD
ABOUT THE MOUTH.
>> WHEN I FIRST
STARTED MODELING--
AND MISS J. KNOWS THIS--
WHEN I FELT LIKE
I WAS FIERCE ON THE RUNWAY,
I BROUGHT ALL OF MY FIERCENESS
INTO MY LIPS.
AND THAT'S WHAT YOU DO.
YOU DON'T DO THE PUSH-OUT.
YOU DO THE...
"I'M FIERCE! MY NAME IS MEGG!"
>> (laughter)
>> CARIDEE.
YOU MESSED UP A LOT,
BUT I FELT
THERE WAS A CERTAIN FUN
THAT YOU HAD WITH IT
THAT FELT LIKE YOU CARED.
BUT WHY ARE YOU SO CONNECTED
TO THIS, LIKE,
POLLYANNA-LIKE HAIR
AND STYLE OF DRESS?
OH, THAT'S BETTER.
>> OH, YEAH.
>> MUCH BETTER.
>> I SMELL WHAT
YOU'RE STEPPING IN.
>> LET'S SEE IF YOU GOT
A GREAT SHOT
AT THE END OF THAT RUNWAY.
>> OH, GOD!
>> I LIKE IT.
IT WENT WITH YOUR PERSONALITY.
>> AND YOU LOOK GOOD
EVEN WITH ONE EYE SHUT.
>> THAT'S WHY I CHOSE IT,
'CAUSE I THOUGHT IT LOOKED LIKE
KAROLINA KURKOVA.
YOU'VE GOTTA BALANCE, LIKE,
HAVING FUN ON THE RUNWAY
BUT SELLING THE CLOTHES.
>> OKAY.
>> BACK IN MY DAY,
I WAS ONE OF THOSE GIRLS
THAT HAD SO MUCH FUN,
THAT DO SO MUCH ON THE RUNWAY,
BUT I WAS CONSTANTLY
THINKING ABOUT
WHAT THE PHOTOGRAPHER
WAS GOING TO CAPTURE.
SO I WAS CONSTANTLY
THINKING ABOUT THE CLOTHES,
EVEN THOUGH I WAS
ACTING A DAMN FOOL.
SO IT'S--YOU STILL HAVE
TO REMEMBER TO RESPECT
THE DESIGNER'S CLOTHES.
MONIQUE.
>> YOU COME ACROSS
AS JUST COMPLETELY VACANT.
>> I'M JUST, LIKE, REALLY SICK
AND, LIKE, REALLY WEAK.
>> TRY AS HARD AS YOU CAN
TO GET A BETTER GAME FACE.
>> THIS INDUSTRY DOESN'T CARE
IF YOU'RE SICK.
>> MNH-MNH.
>> THEY DON'T CARE
IF YOU ARE TIRED.
AND WE'RE BEING HARD
BECAUSE THIS IS THE REAL WORLD.
SO, MONIQUE,
I KNOW THAT YOU DID NOT
DO THE PHOTO SHOOT, RIGHT?
RIGHT?
PHOTO SHOOTS
ARE A REALLY BIG PART
OF THE JUDGES' EVALUATION
OF YOU.
BUT WE STILL HAVE
PLENTY OF OTHER THINGS
TO CONSIDER,
LIKE YOUR OTHER PHOTO SHOOTS
AND YOUR PERFORMANCE
IN THE CHALLENGES
AND YOUR OVERALL PERFORMANCE
AND YOUR POTENTIAL.
>> I JUST WANNA SAY THAT
I REALLY DO WANNA BE HERE,
AND I DO FEEL THAT
I DO HAVE POTENTIAL
TO BE A TOP MODEL.
>> ALL RIGHTY,
UP NEXT IS MELROSE.
>> FOR ME,
THE GREAT THING ABOUT IT WAS
EVERY TIME YOU HAD A MISHAP,
YOU POSED.
>> MELROSE,
YOU DID THE MODEL THING
WHERE YOU WANT THE MODEL
TO LOOK MAD AND PISSED,
BUT GORGEOUS...
AND YOU DID IT.
>> LOOK AT THOSE EYES,
THOSE PIERCING EYES.
>> YEAH, YOU WERE ACTUALLY
THE BEST WALKER.
I WAS LIKE, "WOW!"
>> THANKS.
>> BROOKE.
>> YOU GOT A LITTLE BIT
OF A FRUIT 'N' NUT,
BUT I LIKE THAT ABOUT YOU.
>> NO, I LOVE THAT, TOO,
THAT WHEN YOU CAME OUT,
YOUR BOWL OF FRUIT FELL,
AND INSTEAD OF PICKING IT UP
YOU JUST WENT STRAIGHT THROUGH.
>> YOU COMMITTED TO IT.
SO LET'S SEE HOW YOU DID.
I WISH THIS COULD
BE IN THE DICTIONARY
NEXT TO "WIND IN HAIR
ON RUNWAY."
SO MANY GIRLS GO,
"HOW DO I MAKE MY HAIR BLOW?
I DON'T HAVE A FAN."
YOU CREATE THE FAN,
AND YOU DID THAT
BY PROPELLING FORWARD.
>> THANK YOU.
>> ALL RIGHT, UP NEXT IT A.J.
IT WAS JAPANESE, ZEN-LIKE.
YOU WERE THE CHALLENGE WINNER,
WALKING THE STRAIGHT LINE
ON THE COBBLESTONE.
SO TELL US ABOUT
YOUR AMAZING CHALLENGE WIN.
>> I PICKED MEGG AND CARIDEE
TO GO WITH ME,
AND WE WENT TO AUSTIN, TEXAS,
FOR THE DENNIS QUAID
CHARITY FASHION WEEKEND.
>> LET'S SEE YOUR BEST SHOT.
>> I WOULDN'T KNOW
FROM THAT PHOTOGRAPH
THAT YOU WERE LOSING BALANCE.
>> YOU WORKED IT,
AND IT MADE ME SAY, "OKAY."
>> IF YOU CAN HOLD IT TOGETHER
FOR A MOMENT,
THE CHANCES ARE
A GOOD PHOTOGRAPHER'S
GONNA CAPTURE YOU LOOKING LIKE
YOU'RE NOT GONNA FALL.
>> ANCHAL.
SOME OF THE GIRLS
THAT DID BETTER THAN YOU,
THE THING FELL A MILLION TIMES
OFF THEIR HEAD.
BUT THEY DID BETTER THAN YOU
BECAUSE THEY TRIED.
HERE IS YOUR BEST SHOT.
>> OKAY. IT'S NOT BAD.
>> FOCUSED, SHAPE'S GOOD,
BUT AGAIN,
THE OUTFIT LOOKS FANTASTIC,
AND YOU CAN REALLY SEE IT,
SO YOU'RE SHOWING IT TO US.
>> THE FACE LOOKS A LITTLE WEAK,
EVEN FROM A LONG-DISTANCE SHOT,
SO WE GO TO THE CLOSE-UP.
YOU'RE LUCKY THAT THE OUTFIT
HAS SUCH STRUCTURE
THAT IT MAKES YOU LOOK GOOD.
>> YOU JUST HAVE TO SELL IT MORE
WITH YOUR FACE.
>> THANKS.
>> ALL RIGHT, UP NEXT IS EUGENA.
>> YOUR WALK
NEEDED TO BE SPED UP.
IT DIDN'T HAVE THAT...
>> IT DIDN'T HAVE ZEN.
>> DIDN'T HAVE ZEN.
>> LET'S SEE
IF YOU BROUGHT A FIERCE POSE
AT THE END OF THAT RUNWAY.
>> IT'S NOT GREAT.
I MEAN, AGAIN, THE TOP HALF
LOOKS BETTER THAN
THE BOTTOM HALF,
BUT YOU WERE
ON A MOVING PLATFORM.
>> I ACTUALLY SLIPPED
AND FELL ON IT, AND, LIKE,
BUSTED MY KNEES AND STUFF.
>> I FIND YOUR PHOTOGRAPHS--
AND THIS ONE INCLUDED--
VERY, VERY DISAPPOINTING.
YOU'RE KIND OF WITHDRAWN,
AND YOUR EYES ARE DEAD.
>> THIS IS THE THIRD TIME
THAT YOU'VE HEARD THE JUDGES SAY
THAT YOU'RE NOT CONNECTING
WITH YOUR EYES,
THAT YOU'RE RESTING
ON SOMETHING.
I WOULD'VE LIKED
TO SEE YOU HAVE MORE POWER.
YOU WERE LIKE, "OKAY,"
RATHER THAN, "OKAY."
MR. JAY SAID THAT
YOU WERE THE ONLY GIRL TO FALL,
"THE WORST OF THE DAY."
SO NOW IT IS TIME
FOR THE JUDGES TO DELIBERATE,
AND WHEN I CALL YOU BACK,
I WILL ANNOUNCE
WHICH ONE OF YOU
WILL BE ELIMINATED.
>> ALL RIGHT, SO NOW IT IS TIME
TO DECIDE WHO IS GOING HOME.
ARE YOU READY?
>> YEP.
>> OH, I'M READY.
>> MICHELLE.
>> MICHELLE LOOKS INCREDIBLE
IN THIS PICTURE.
THIS SHOWS THAT
MICHELLE CAN DELIVER
A STRONG FASHION PICTURE
EVEN ON A WOBBLY, UH, RUNWAY.
>> I NEED HER TO IMPRESS ME
IN FRONT OF ME
THE WAY SHE DOES HERE.
>> JAEDA.
>> JAEDA SURPRISES ME,
'CAUSE JAEDA, FOR ME,
IS THE GIRL RUNNING LOWEST...
>> MM-HMM.
>> IN THE ENTIRE PACK.
THIS WEEK--
THE BIGGEST IMPROVEMENT.
>> AMANDA.
>> I THINK SHE'S INTERESTING.
THAT QUIRKY BODY
NEEDS A BIT MORE WORK IN PERSON.
>> ANCHAL.
>> I THINK SHE COULD
BE SUPER, SUPER UNIQUE.
I MEAN, THERE'S NOT VERY MANY
INDIAN SUPERMODELS OUT THERE.
>> SHE WAS
TERRIBLY NERVOUS TODAY.
SHE'S NOT A HAPPY BUNNY.
>> A.J.
>> IF YOU'D HAVE SHOWN ME
THIS PICTURE,
AND SAID IT'S A NEW MODEL
THAT'S JUST BEEN SIGNED
BY A BIG AGENCY,
I'D HAVE BELIEVED IT.
>> MEGG.
>> MEGG--WITH HER EYES SHUT
AND HER MOUTH OPEN,
OR HER MOUTH SHUT
AND HER EYES OPEN...
>> WHY DO I LIKE HER?
>> BECAUSE SHE'S GOT THAT
CUTENESS ABOUT HER.
>> (imitates Megg)
"ROCK AND ROLL!"
>> BROOKE.
>> I LOVE WHAT SHE DID
IN HER CHALLENGE.
IT MADE ME LAUGH.
>> THE BEST THING ABOUT BROOKE
WAS WHEN SHE WAS
WALKING DOWN THE RUNWAY,
AND IT WAS ALL ABOUT HER HAIR.
IT WAS LIKE...
(makes whooshing sounds)
>> MELROSE.
>> MELROSE REALLY
LOOKS LIKE A MODEL.
FACE IS STRONG.
THE BODY LANGUAGE, I LIKE.
>> EUGENA.
SHE FEELS LIKE
SHE'S SPARKLING INSIDE
BUT IT'S NOT COMING OUT.
IF YOU ARE FEELING SOMETHING,
AND PEOPLE KEEP ON SAYING
THEY DON'T SEE IT,
YOU NEED TO EXAGGERATE.
>> EUGENA REALLY IS
LIKE A DEAD FISH.
>> DEAD FISH GIVE YOU THIS
BEFORE IT'S DYING, AT LEAST...
>> (laughter)
>> SHE'S NOT EVEN GIVING THAT?
>> NO, SHE'S NOT EVEN
GIVING YOU THAT.
>> WELL, PERHAPS SHE MIGHT
GIVE US THAT
IF WE GET RID OF HER. UM...
>> (gasps)
I LIKE THIS PICTURE OF CARIDEE.
I THINK SHE'S
GIVING PERSONALITY,
BUT SHE IS GIVING MODEL.
>> I DON'T THINK
I WOULD WANNA BE THE STYLIST
ON A PHOTO SHOOT WITH HER.
WHEN SHE'S SITTING THERE,
SHE HAS TO BE, YOU KNOW, POSED,
AND SHE'S--SHE JUST SEEMS LIKE
SHE'D BE ALL OVER THE PLACE,
LIKE, "HA HA!"
(cuckoo clock sounds)
>> OH, WE LOVE CUCKOO.
>> OKAY, SO MONIQUE
DIDN'T DO THE PHOTO SHOOT,
SO WE HAVE TO JUDGE
HER PAST PHOTOS,
AND ALSO HER OVERALL PERFORMANCE
IN THIS COMPETITION.
>> FOR ME, MONIQUE'S
ONE OF THE MOST
BEAUTIFUL GIRLS HERE.
SHE'S SO STUNNING.
>> ESPECIALLY WHEN SHE SMILES.
OH, SHE IS SICK, I'M SURE.
>> YEAH.
>> BUT I FEEL LIKE SHE'S PUTTING
ALL OF IT INTO "I'M SICK,"
NOT THAT "I'M STRESSED,"
NOT THAT "I'M SCARED,"
NOT THAT "I'M INTIMIDATED,"
NOT THAT
"I CAN'T TAKE THIS CRITIQUE."
IT'S JUST, "I'M SICK."
>> AND BY THE WAY,
ALL THOSE THINGS THAT YOU
JUST LISTED ARE THINGS THAT
CAN ACTUALLY MAKE YOU SICK...
>> YEAH.
>> IF YOU CAN'T HANDLE IT.
>> ♪ SHE DON'T WANT ♪
♪ TO BE HERE ♪
♪ NO, SHE DON'T ♪
♪ SHE DON'T WANNA BE HERE ♪
>> ♪ NO, NO, NO ♪
>> ♪ NO, SHE DON'T ♪
♪ SHE DON'T WANNA BE HERE ♪
♪ SEND HER HOME ♪
>> ♪ SHE DON'T WANNA ♪
♪ BE HERE NO MORE ♪
>> ♪ WHOO ♪
>> ♪ SHE DON'T WANNA BE HERE ♪
>> ♪ OH, NO ♪
♪ SHE DON'T WANNA BE HERE ♪
>> ♪ OOH, LORD ♪
>> ♪ SHE DON'T WANNA BE HERE ♪
>> ♪ I DON'T KNOW ♪
♪ IF SHE SHOULD GO ♪
♪ I'M NOT SURE ♪
♪ IF SHE SHOULD STAY ♪
♪ SHE MIGHT NEED US ♪
♪ TO REACH DOWN ♪
♪ AND LIFT HER UP ♪
>> WHOO!
>> (laughter)
♪♪
>> 11 GIRLS STAND BEFORE ME,
BUT UNFORTUNATELY,
ONLY TEN OF YOU
WILL STILL BE IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
THE FIRST NAME
THAT I AM GOING TO CALL
IS...
A.J.
WORK IT.
UNH-UNH,
YOU WANT THIS, MM-HMM?
THERE YOU GO.
WHOA!
GAVE ME CHILLS!
>> (laughs)
>> CONGRATULATIONS...
>> THANK YOU.
>> YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
THE NEXT NAME
THAT I AM GOING TO CALL
IS...
JAEDA.
WE LIKE THAT HAIR CURLY.
>> THANK YOU.
>> MISS "WIND IN HER HAIR"
BROOKE.
>> ALL RIGHT.
>> ANCHAL.
>> (gasps) YES!
>> MICHELLE.
OKAY, TRY TO WALK'
WITH SOME POISE.
GET IT TOGETHER.
IT'S A LITTLE "3-YEAR-OLD GIRL
IN HER MAMA'S HEELS..."
>> THANK YOU.
>> BUT YOU'RE GETTING THERE.
>> OKAY.
>> CONGRATULATIONS.
(whispering) MELROSE.
OH, YEAH, WORK IT OUT.
(normal voice) MEGG.
EVERYBODY'S JUST
WORKING IT TODAY, AREN'T THEY?
>> (laughs) THANKS.
>> (imitates Megg)
CONGRATULATIONS, MEGG!
>> THANK YOU.
>> (normal voice) AMANDA.
OKAY,
STILL TWO LEFT FEET.
WHAT IS UP WITH
YOU AND YOUR SISTER?
THE NEXT NAME
THAT I'M GOING TO CALL
IS...
(whispers) CARIDEE.
>> OH, JEEZ!
>> (laughter)
>> NO, I CAN'T EVEN--
JUST GIVE IT!
>> CONGRATULATIONS, CARIDEE.
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
>> OH!
THANK YOU FOR BELIEVING IN ME.
>> OH, GOSH, JADE.
>> THANK YOU
FOR BELIEVING IN ME.
THANK YOU FOR BELIEVING IN ME.
(crying) THANK YOU
FOR BELIEVING IN ME ONCE AGAIN.
>> I ONLY HAVE ONE PHOTO
IN MY HANDS,
AND I'M ONLY GONNA CALL
ONE NAME.
THE GIRL THAT I DO NOT CALL
MUST IMMEDIATELY
RETURN TO THE HOUSE,
PACK HER BELONGINGS
AND GO HOME.
NOW THIS PHOTO IN MY HANDS,
IT MIGHT BE A PHOTO
ON A VERY ROCKY RUNWAY...
OR IT MIGHT BE A PHOTO
FROM LAST WEEK.
THERE IS SO MUCH POTENTIAL
IN BOTH OF YOU...
UNDENIABLE BEAUTY,
AND IT IS SO FRUSTRATING
THAT YOU ALL CAN'T
BRING ACROSS THIS AMAZING BEAUTY
INTO A PHOTO.
MONIQUE,
WE LOOK AT YOU AND WONDER,
"DOES SHE WANT THIS ENOUGH?"
WE'VE HAD GIRLS ON "TOP MODEL"
THAT HAVE BEEN SICK...
I.V.s, OXYGEN--
BUT THEY'VE GOTTEN UP,
AND THEY'VE TREKKED
THROUGH THE JUNGLE
ON AN ELEPHANT
TO DO A PHOTO SHOOT.
SO WE WONDER,
"JUST HOW SICK WAS SHE?"
AND EVEN IF SHE WAS SICK,
MAYBE HER PHOTOS
AREN'T AS STRONG.
WHEN THE JUDGES
LOOK AT YOU, EUGENA--
THE COCKY GIRL THAT SAID,
"ALL THOSE GIRLS IN CYCLE SIX
HAVE NOTHING ON ME.
I AM IT."
BUT YOU'RE NOWHERE NEAR
THOSE GIRLS IN CYCLE SIX.
NOWHERE NEAR THEM.
SO YOU ALL ARE NECK AND NECK.
SO WHICH ONE OF YOU GOES HOME?
>> EUGENA,
WE KNOW THAT YOU HAVE IT.
>> (sighs)
>> WE KNOW THAT YOU DO.
BUT IF IT'S STUCK IN YOUR HEAD,
WE'LL NEVER SEE IT.
CONGRATULATIONS,
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
>> (mouths words)
>> MELROSE IS GONNA
HAVE A FREAKIN' PARTY.
SHE'LL PROBABLY BUST OUT
THE CELEBRATION HATS
AND HORNS AND STUFF.
THAT'S THE PART
THAT REALLY JUST SUCKS,
'CAUSE I DON'T WANT TO GIVE HER
THE SATISFACTION OF ME LEAVING.
I JUST FELT
THAT THIS WHOLE TIME HERE
WAS, HONESTLY, A WASTE.
THAT'S ALL I HAVE TO SAY.
FAREWELL.
♪♪
>> COMING UP ON
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL"...
>> HOW MANY GIRLS CAN YOU FIT
IN THE DAMN SHOWER?
>> MELROSE STRUGGLES
TO KEEP ORDER
IN THE "TOP MODEL" HOUSE...
>> WELL, JUST TRY AND, LIKE,
BE RESPECTFUL IF SOME PEOPLE
ARE TRYING TO GET
THAT THREE HOURS OF SLEEP.
>> AND ANCHAL'S ROOMMATES
AGGRAVATE HER INSECURITIES...
>> AS THIS COMPETITION GOES ON,
SHE'S NOT BECOMING
MORE BEAUTIFUL.
>> YEAH.
>> (crying) I DON'T UNDERSTAND!